[Music]
[Applause]
he's dan orlowski the former nfl
quarterback you can
check him out weekdays on espn's nfl
live at 4 eastern also contributes to uh
some other programs on the mother ship
including get up sportscenter first take
and more
i always learn something when we have
him on and dan joins us on the program
dan good morning explain that logic to
me that the niners can't play at home
but they're going to play in arizona
where the covid situation as far as
testing
is higher twice as high as it is in
santa clara
shouldn't be talking about football
often so
my brain cells can't figure that out but
i know um
they found a way to make their games
happen which is the most important thing
to the nfl
and um hopefully everyone stays safe but
that's above my pay grade but it feels
like this is
whatever it takes to get to the
postseason we saw this with the nba in
the bubble the nhl and the bubble
we saw this with major league baseball
does the nfl have blinders on
that it's just whatever it takes we're
playing these games even if it's not a
true representation
of the teams that uh we expect to be on
the field
yeah i think a little bit i i think that
the reality is this i actually got into
a friend of mine who's an attorney last
night about this because
she asked me do you think the season is
going to be viewed the same or watered
down i said no i think i think because
there's a lot of challenges tied to it
that it'll still be weighed
equally if not greater because of those
challenges i said i do
think that this week needs to be a huge
learning example for the nfl because
you know the ravens have to play their
game because of their covet outbreak
they got a thousand starters out but a
lot of like
you know their quarterbacks out which is
obviously a huge deal and it may not be
that big a deal because it's the regular
season
and there's 16 games and
it's not a lose and go home sudden death
environment
but what would happen if it was the
first or second round of the playoffs
and it's patrick mahomes
or it's aaron rodgers and those guys
can't play in that game
because of contact tracing or something
that's a huge
problem for the nfl and it is sudden
death
win or go home type of thing and so um i
get it that they want to get to the
playoffs
but they need to learn from this past
week because that that would be
unacceptable
i was watching the game yesterday and i
thought who's going to lose this game it
wasn't who's going to win this game
but i got the feeling that the steelers
were playing down
to and i give the ravens credit but did
i learn more from the ravens should i
learn more about the ravens or the
steelers yesterday
i think yesterday's game is a really
difficult game just
to judge the steelers off of haven't had
a lot of structure they've missed
practices they played once
they didn't know when their game was
going to happen so i think it is a
tough game to judge them off of how good
of a football team they are
the steelers are a really good football
team um
we know what their flaw is they're not
explosive on offense
it's going to be hard to win a super
bowl without being explosive in 2020
but they are super clutch i mean they
got guys that are clutch they're going
to be in every fourth quarter game
and they've got guys and big ben and
really juju who are clutch
players i think we learned a little bit
about the ravens defensively
uh i i agree with you i thought the
ravens actually lost that game
i was uh texting our nfl live crew and i
said if i was the ravens i would not
throw more than three passes in the
second half
and there was a there was a drive of
theirs in the
back end of the third quarter and it got
the second and eight
at like the 40-yard line and they went
drop back pass
sack third and 20. i would have just run
the ball
just continue to run the football
because you weren't gonna win that game
throwing it yeah you were gonna lose the
game throwing it
and um i think we learned a little bit
about the ravens more
more so than the steelers yeah i was
sort of well i i
thought what the ravens showed me is
something maybe you build off of and
chris collins word talked about that
that
you know maybe they look back on this
and say you know we kind of came
together when nobody thought we could
come together
but i forget who we had on who said it
it seems like lamar jackson's taking a
step back and i wonder if defenses have
taken a step
up uh at the same time to coincide with
lamar jackson like has he taken a step
back or
the defenses sort of stepped up a little
bit more here
i think the defenses have stepped up a
little bit more you know dan when he was
drafted when he was coming out
i really said two things about lamar i
said listen lamar's got a chance to be a
really good player
if he used the right way and they have
used him the right way up until this
point
but i also said this when you take a guy
like lamar
you have to go all in with everything
you have to go all in with scheme
and you have to go all in with the
people around that scheme
it can't be a traditional nfl offensive
roster
you have to have very specific offensive
linemen that are part of your run game
they're better run game blockers than
pass game blockers
you have to have very specific tight
ends that are part of your run game
more so than your vertical stretch pass
game and you got to have very specific
receivers
and so to make it work they went all in
and when one of those
pieces gets taken away it has a bigger
impact
than your traditional nfl offensive
personnel wise because
you know when you're a green bay packers
you can have a multitude of backs that
fix
fit your offense or offensive linemen or
wide receivers
because they don't have to be so
specific to the scheme
with the ravens they have to and when
one gets picked off it's it's a bigger
crack than a normal crack and i think
if you look at this team compared to
last year's like
the offensive line is different and it's
harder to find those people to replace
those different offensive linemen the
same with the tight end so
it's the perfect storm of like the
injuries have have been impactful
defenses have caught up
you're more predictable because your
playbook is smaller
when you go all in in that offense um
and i think lamar is is i i don't look
at it as lamar has taken this step back
i think the
um the confusion that they created
against defenses last year
isn't as confusing you stan orlovsky
espn nfl live
analyst if i said you can have the
chiefs of the field to win the super
bowl
chiefs in a runaway no one's beating
them here
here's i wrote this down this morning
this is how the chiefs are
going to not win the super bowl this
year i want to find my notes okay
the chiefs to not win the super bowl um
that you you have to hope that they play
their c game which
they haven't really this year you have
to hold the ball
as long as you possibly can i don't care
how you hold it
you have to hold it if it's your run
game great if it's your perimeter screen
game it's the quick game in the past
game
that's fine you have to force threes and
not sevens on defense
at least three times you got to make
them kick a field goal
and not a touchdown you have to make
them drive the field
you've got to stop the explosive pass
game you know so many coordinators go we
got to stop the runyon no
you have to stop the explosive pass game
make mahomes play boring football
um you've got to be able to have a
quarterback that can create special
plays as much as mahomes does he's got
to match the
i went above the x's and o's plays as
much as my
homes does so um and then in the fourth
quarter you got to make more big plays
people think it's the tennessee titans
that can beat the chiefs
if if you told me they had taylor lawan
i'd be a little bit more on board with
that
uh i think the team that can do it is
the buffalo bills um i think the bills
can go punch for punch with them
offensively
i think their quarterback can make some
like weird plays
that go above x's and o's and they can
be explosive offensively
but kansas city was lucky to win the
super bowl last year
dan i go back to the knee injury with
patrick mahomes
then you get to the playoffs where they
could have easily lost
all of those games but nothing is
different like
i that that's fair but if they go down
14
i still 100 unequivocally believe in
them
like i just their their quarterback does
so much stuff
with his physical talent and then his
brain like it's
he sees things so fast because if they
go down 14 they're still gonna have 50
plus snaps
that's why like the holding the football
is such a big deal and yes they probably
could have
and arguably should have lost the super
bowl but that was
a ridiculously good defense in in san
francisco
another team that i would give you that
i would i think the cults have a chance
because they're cut the same way as as
san francisco was last year
um i just i look at that offense and i
go
there's no flaw kelsey's the best player
in football that's not a quarterback
um and wait wait you think kelsey is
he's the best player who's not a
quarterback yeah wow
over aaron donald and he does what
over aaron donald i mean
for me yes because just because
he brings so much offense to their
offense before the ball
ever gets snapped i mean the the amount
of times they place him
in in specific positions to get the
coverage
is is like is such a a advantage
because it doesn't just affect the
outcome of the play after the snap like
he will
go out there and they'll put a corner
out there and mahomes knows it's going
to be zone and then he'll go to
two high safeties here comes run game
and for me
like that six yard run is huge
because now there's nothing you as a
defense can do
like i can literally go to the line of
scrimmage and get into whatever play i
want
as great as aaron is he's remarkable but
he doesn't create
defense before the snap as much as
kelsey creates offense
but could you do you think we're going
to look at kelsey as
being the greatest tight end of all time
when it's all said and done
um i mean
i there's if they go on the dynasty run
like i expect them to over the next five
years absolutely i mean he's on a
historic season
run this year mike has grown to the
greatest tight end of all time
yes gronk's the greatest tight end of
all time and gronk is the first guy that
did this stuff
yeah like gronk is the first guy that
did all this for brady
and um you know i know he was probably
more impactful in the run game
i'm not a person who looks at that stuff
at the end of the day does my offense
score a lot of points in this this guy
help us do it
you know and so that's why i think
kelsey's got a chance to do that you had
a tweet a couple of days ago that i
mentioned on the air that
they hear the saints who haven't been
fully assembled uh michael thomas drew
brees they played two games together
that defense is great uh yeah are the
are the saints the team to beat the nfc
they are you know and i i was i was
hard-headed on this for about
five weeks six weeks of this season
because i still go how are they going to
be explosive on offense
i don't think you can win a super bowl
without being explosive on offense right
now i just don't
um because you're going to have to get
28 points at least
maybe even more on kansas city right
yeah and i just
i go can you screen pass and efficient
pass game your way
down the field that consistently and
and create those chunk plays to win a
bunch of games especially when you need
to in the playoffs right now and
i struggle with buying into that but at
the same time
the difference between the defense right
now and to where it was
you know mid-october so to speak and
certainly in september was like they're
not giving up though
what are you guys doing bone-headed
blown coverage plays
they've you know rectified a lot of that
um i think the
the the addition of quan alexander was
huge for their linebacker core and
coverage so
that's been really good they're playing
much better on defense but
the fact that they're sitting at nine
and two and haven't had those guys just
tells you two things
the depth of their football team is real
and that they're
as well coached as anyone in football i
mean shawn is as good as anyone in
football we can put sean with bill
belichick's staff we can put sean with
andy reid's staff we can put sean
with mcvay staff and two things that get
separated or
separate you in the playoffs outside of
having a stupid quarterback is
you gotta have depth and you gotta be
well coached and the saints are right
there
always great to talk to you dan we
appreciate your time thanks for joining
us
thanks guys that's stan orlovsky espn
nfl live analyst you can catch him
weekdays on espn nfl live at 4
eastern also on get up and sports center
first take